dans koh lanta il ya une épreuve
évidemment on aime ou pas l'épreuve qui
recule c'est bien sûr l'épreuve de
dégustation oui nous allons faire cette
épreuve sur ce plateau où là parce que à
la clé il y aura une immunité une
immunité
[Rires]
il fait moins bien
j'ai vraiment au sérieux cette époque
chers amis chroniqueur parce que grâce à
ce jeu de luminy nez vous pour être
immunisé pour la pour l'élimination d'un
les chroniqueurs qui ne pourra pas
participer au débat de koh lanta ça veut
pas dire je mets juste qu'il pourra
rentrer chez lui plutôt ça veut dire
qu'il sera ça veut dire qu'il sera mis
de côté mais des moments d'eau d'à côté
il ya des pipis les les cocos pipi caca
ces derniers mois il ya les jaunes et
les rouges verts alors on va vous
épargner mais non gilles verdez koh
lanta c'est pas facile
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez toutefois mettre un bandeau
c'est quelque chose dont tous les sièges
ou si il y à sousse et il y as où ces
deux cloches là on va commencer par
celle là d'accord ok alors dans ces
clauses qui peut y avoir différentes
choses regard défiant la reine
la rayer y est très bonne et très bon et
très bon dans la sambre
ou alors le sympathique un flamby je
vous rappelle le principe on ne choisit
pas ses collants je vous rappelle le
principe de cette épreuve de dégustation
manger la chose qui est dans l'assiette
le plus rapidement possible on doit quoi
faire après d'aisé n'en tirait la langue
c'est qu'on n'ait plus rien dans la
bouche
alors toi pour cette année se sont
brûlés est normal mais c'est moi qui
suis en train de cramer
je gère la situation c'est moi c'est
pour cette épreuve j'appelle ludivine
ces flux divine là c'est le divine face
aux jamaïquains la sagem face à qui
fasse mais sauve à lille sont ils sont
dans la même équipe en est ce que
clément se faire percer noms d'animaux à
dispenser un petit trou du coup je fais
pas mal aimé du tout du tout
[Rires]
attendez attendez touchés par les mains
sur les cloches messine il aime trop
tard il ya et il y à une immunité à
gagner à la suite de l'émission il faut
manger le plus nul éliminé vrai j'étais
en fait je vais vomir mais n'ont battu
bave au musée par lasser
vraiment je tourne au mit et la donation
attention trois 2 1 go
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la veille avait il y avait quand même un
petit exercice c'est bon tu sais pas si
c'est en tout cas ça donne protéines tu
sais quoi de pire où c'était quoi un
oeil non ainsi que des revers blancs oui
c'est son vivant c'est autre chose jean
me contre magali non c'est les mêmes et
qu'ils savent c'est délicieux on veut
gens me contre francesca
si c'est un oeil de poisson je ne fais
pas un drame et evola attention oussalah
derrière et on fait là quel nom et est
ce que je dire mais là non je vais
mettre la regarder ah oui mais non c'est
lui c'est un produit non ces mêmes
produits on va attendre et on aime bien
l année un pognon dans ses missions
attention à elle alors je vous rappelle
qu'ils restent soit une araignée je te
sois un flamby allez on n'a pas mangé
une réunion comme moulineaux en
attendant au nord est bon c'est un
bonheur est si vite arrivé attention
aller francesca les années 2
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
bah oui maxime maximini et daniel moreau
il a bouclé myhtique a été horrible
allez allez allez allez
attention à lait de nuit et aval sur
tout avaler vous n'y a pas sans surprise
normalement ça devrait bien se passer ça
doit être un flan attendait parfois dans
koh lanta et des agnelles à ça
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
allez dernière non non non non non
ouais
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors excusez moi pour me dire qu'il est
le problème
le décès de ce flanc il n'était pas
frais de bière ce que c'est bon j'ai ma
piano va sano de daniel et laura ça
cette belle victoire
r vous gagner l'immunité
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]